Однією з головних передвиборчих обіцянок Володимира Зеленського
та партії "Слуга народу" було зняття депутатської недоторканності.
І вже на одному з перших засідань новообрані депутати взялись її виконувати.
Третього вересня парламентарі проголосували за законопроект,
що вносив зміни до Конституції України та прибрав з головного закону
норми про недоторканність народних обранців.
Утім, де-факто депутатський імунітет нікуди не подівся,
визнають самі депутати.
Зараз у нас така дивна ситуація:
в Конституції у нас недоторканості немає, але в законах,
якими фактично прислуховуються слідчі і судді,
в кримінально-процесуальному кодексі недоторканість є.
Йдеться про норми в кримінально-процесуальному кодексі,
законі "Про статус народного депутата" та законі "Про регламент Верховної Ради".
Без відповідних змін до цих законів правоохоронним органам, як і раніше,
не дозволятиметься проводити слідчі дії стосовно народних обранців
без згоди Верховної Ради. А остаточна ліквідація
такого поняття, як недоторканність, неможлива.
В цих законах норми лишаються.
Це означає, що якщо їх звідти не дістати,
то другого січня, навіть коли зміни в конституції запрацюють,
не можна буде прослуховувати, обшукувати, слідкувати за депутатом
без дозволу Ради.
Не можна буде йому вручити підозру, затримати, заарештувати без дозволу Ради.
Здавалося б, логічним наступним кроком є внесення парламентом
необхідних змін до решти законів, які містять норми про недоторканність народних депутатів.
Президент Зеленський виконав свою частину роботи
та подав до Верховної Ради законопроект 1009,
що мав би суттєво вплинути на остаточне зняття депутатської недоторканності.
Однак, як виявилось, депутати зі "Слуги народу" не такі вже й одностайні,
коли йдеться про ліквідацію привілею, яким роками зловживали численні народні обранці.
Зупиніть голосування, зупиніть!
Перший раз не вистачило критично голосів у "Слуги народу",
тому що усередині фракції почались маніпуляції.
Частина працівників фракції почала розповідати іншій частині
менш досвідченій, про те, що ну, все, вас там будуть прослуховувати
за рішенням районного слідчого.
Їм просто показувались правки і казали – бачите тепер вас будуть слухати без дозволу судді.
Всіх слухають з дозволом судді, а вас без.
Після першого провалу у Верховній Раді все ще покладалися надії
на успішне повторне голосування президентського законопроекту.
Проте депутати з правлячої партії вирішили видалити з нього частину норм,
що стосувались депутатської недоторканності.
У "Слузі народу" виправдовуються: мовляв, про провал говорити ще зарано.
Тут є дещо маніпуляція,
яку деякі громадські активісти, назвемо їх так,
використали для того, щоб розігнати величезну зраду,
ому що ми ще тоді прийняли рішення про те,
що цю норму потрібно винести в окремий законопроект.
Новий законопроект, за словами Янченко,
має скасовувати всі норми щодо депутатської недоторканності,
які залишись в законодавстві.
Окрім цього, він міститиме такі собі запобіжники,
які захищали б народних обранців від незаконного переслідування.
Таким запобіжником ми пропонуємо бути генеральному прокурору.
Тобто практично генеральний прокурор згідно з законопроекту,
який був поданий, він має реєструвати
в ЄРДР початок кримінального провадження,
він має погоджувати наприклад клопотання до суду про проведення обшуків,
про проведення прослуховування і так далі по народним депутатам.
Утім, такі пояснення викликають недовіру громадських активістів та антикорупціонерів.
На їхню думку, поява нових законопроектів  та затягування процесу
свідчать про небажання остаточно позбавитися нодоторканності.
Поясність мені логіку.
Нащо було забирати з законопроекту президента норми,
які ви збираєтесь все одно проголосувати?
Що вони отримали з цього, окрім скандалу? Нічого.
Тому, якщо ціллю було проголосувати ці норми,
то це спокійно можна було робити в 1009 президента.
Я великий скептик, що все буде так просто, як вони розповідають.
Тим часом в Україні й надалі існуватиме колізія,
коли правоохоронці будуть намагатись проводити слідчі дії стосовно депутатів,
а ті, в свою чергу, оскаржуватимуть будь-які подібні кроки у судах.
Яскравий приклад -  гучна "бурштинова" справа нині екс-депутата
Верховної Ради Борислава Розенблата.
У Раду нового скликання він, попри обіцянку
"дитячий майданчик у кожен двір!" не потрапив.
А от у Раді минулого скликання він успішно уник арешту,
незважаючи на  обґрунтовані підозри антикорупційних відомств
у зловживанні ним владою та хабарництві.
Нині ж Розенблат навіть позивається проти дій НАБУ.
НАБУ мало попросити в парламенту дозвіл
на прослуховування Розенблата. Парламент мав би прийняти рішення,
публічно про це проголосувавши
в прямому ефірі з журналістами.
Який сенс після цього Розенблата слухати
або обшуковувати, або спостереження вести?
Та там жодного немає сенсу.
Ці норми спеціально і існують,
щоб було не можливо розслідувати депутатів.
Чи розпрощаються депутати з привілейованим статусом
та почнуть відповідати перед законом на рівні з іншими громадянами країни?
Судячи з висловлювань під час пресмарафону,
нині в цьому вже сумнівається і сам президент.
Володимир Зеленський не виключив, що у разі нескасування депутатської недоторканності
парламент буде розпущено знову.